call it
hey guys help Italians name today we're
going to be trying the new unicorn
frappuccinos from Starbucks I am so
excited about this because first of all
they're absolutely beautiful so before
these completely melt all over the place
I'm going to try them and let you guys
know what
we got one of each this is the tall this
is the grande and this is the Vinci this
is a lot of drink so without further ado
let's take a taste
[Music]
oh my good it's like I have a sour taste
I was not expecting that at all
you tricked me I thought this was gonna
be like some sort of sweet little treat
boom oh my goodness I'm so quiet I am so
confused like even the top like a
sprinkle and sprinkles are sour did we
all hit troll what's happening my eyes
are watering mmm oh my gosh Oh crane I
just tasted a little bit of bubble gum
[Music]
and now that's it tasted like milk what
is this stuff on the side let's try to
get in there taste that the blue stuff
it tastes blue an island roll without
edge like well are you okay I'm so
confused
like upon further mixing the sourness is
starting to go away so those sprinkles
on top man I'm telling you what
[Music]
I can't stop tasting them they're so
sour I had no idea I have a very
sensitive case when it comes to sour
things but Wow
mmm all right let's keep mixing it's
starting to turn pink all these colors
and mixtures boy :
it tastes like a jolly rancher mixed
with like a sour patch kids and some
milk with a dash of sangria what are you
what are you I keep tasting it because I
just I don't know what it is sweet and
fruity transforming to pleasantly sour
swirl to reveal a color-changing
spectral purple in pink will definitely
turn pink these other ones are already
started mill simian greens is ice milk
cream Frappuccino syrup whipped cream
maple syrup blue drizzle which is white
chocolate mocha sauce interesting pink
powder power blue Tatjana sour is sour
I look forward to you guys trying these
and seeing what you think my eyes are
watering a little bit it's way more sour
than I thought I'm going to taste this
one and see you gotta mix it or else
you're getting some sour tree mmm so the
bottom of this one is good who needs it
bubbled up the bottom of this one Oh God
maybe I don't know but they put a lot of
sour in that one wow it's crazy I do it
again
[Music]
okay well now the tower isn't there any
longer I'm confused
okay that's it I mean there's nothing
more that I can say about this I mean
I'm basically case testing a Frappuccino
so clearly how much be said I think it
tastes really good it's probably it
wouldn't be a go-to drink of mine I mean
I basically drink black coffee at
Starbucks that usually might go to my
second go-to is almond cinnamon mocha
Otto and a coconut mocha macchiato these
are good I like it it's definitely the
good limited time drink hmm
I clearly drank all the sour out of this
one all right I'll see you guys my next
video let me know what you guys think if
you try them now I Tommy pickles I'm
sorry guys later bye
[Music]
you